zum ersten mal seit 16 jahren ist die
cdu in der opposition klar ist die
partei muss sich erneuern und wir haben
einen geheimtipp bekommen hier hinter
dieser tür soll die zukunft der cdu
liegen
so herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
hier mitten in berlin wohnt die cdu
zentrale lage mit ölheizung von adenauer
bis märz was für eine partei was für
eine geschichte je wieder freiheit haben
vor uns liegen große aufgaben wahr mir
gott helfe bild bitte nicht die cdu es
war mir eine ehre hanna als hanno
pauline dies ist ein film über
modernisierungsstau über ein leben in
der opposition und der angst vor dem
verschwinden eine journalistische reise
in unbegreifliche welten die noch nie
ein mensch zuvor gehörte na gut wir
haben einen journalisten getroffen der
wirklich ahnung hat alexander der große
ein mann von welt
herr alexander die schlechte nachricht
zuerst wir wollen mit ihnen über die cdu
reden das habe ich vermutet und es gibt
keine gute nachricht
was war das das große geheimnis von
angela merkel
sie hat die wahlen gewonnen
also dafür hätte ich sie jetzt als
experte nicht gebraucht
hatten friedrich merz jetzt mit seinen
vielen kandidaturen überzeugt oder hat
er die partei einfach zum beruf ja das
ist ja lustig es gibt eine schöne
anekdote von friedrich merz als der von
angela merkel besiegt wurde zog er sich
einen sauerland zurück und wurde aus
trotz reich und in dieser zeit gab es
immer versuche von cdu leute nun wieder
ins boot zu holen und die cdu anekdote
erzählt dass merz gesagt hat was sich
vor einem europaparlament jetzt weichen
bundestag jetzt sollte ich auf
landesebene mitmachen und dann soll er
den verbürgten satz gesagt haben ich
warte einfach bis die alte weg ist
das wurde jahrelang als in der cdu als
wahnsinnig witzige anekdote erzählt aber
genauso ist das
ist die cdu eine stolze partei mit fast
800 1000 mitgliedern das war 1990 jetzt
sind es nur noch knapp 400.000
mitglieder oder wie horst seehofer sagen
würde zweimal
200.000
klar ist die cdu muss sich erneuern
deswegen hat die partei reagiert und
eine junge moderne person zum parteichef
gemacht sie heißt
es mit 66 jahren der aufbruch der cdu da
kann man fast schon
weniger lustig 46 prozent aller wähler
fanden bei der bundestagswahl das thema
klima am wichtigsten aber nur prozent
sparen der union in diesem bereich
kompetenzen zu bei den eisbären glaubt
dass sogar nur jeder neunte und das
obwohl einer der ersten
umweltministerinnen aus der cdu kam eine
frau die heute niemand mehr kennt auch
anderswo gibt es defizite die
unionsfraktion ist die fraktion mit dem
geringsten anteil von menschen mit
migrationshintergrund das sind nur 4,1
prozent im ganzen land sind es 27 2
prozent mit einem viertel der
bevölkerung kommt friedrich merz also
höchstens in berührung wenn er sich in
berlin und ein döner kauft
irgendwo im sauerland hier hat man das
weltgeschehen auch fest im blick
allerdings sind hier alle
autobahnbrücken kaputt
wir kamen trotzdem mit dem verbrenner
hier wollen wir friedrich merz treppen
zu einem launigen täter ted einem
treffen auf augenhöhe einem gespräch
unter guten alten bekannten
so friedrich merz hält jetzt seine große
rede und dann immer ganz um exklusive
unterteilen
er hat mir hat friedrich merz bisher
viel richtig gemacht oder profitiert er
noch davon dass die ampel ich sag mal
noch in der findungsphase ist das zweite
ist richtig es ist nämlich so dass als
oppositionsführer man immer nur so gut
sein kann wie regierung schlecht ist man
zeigt auf die schwächen und versucht
risse die sich auftun noch ein bisschen
breiter zu machen man streut salz in die
wunden also man braucht er durchaus eine
destruktive energie und die hat er also
dass ghana oder nee sich dieses plakat
frag sie mal wenn sie einen kleinen
augenblick mal still sein können wer
beschränkt sie da hinten eigentlich dem
ihrer meinungsfreiheit wer wer sagt
ihnen eigentlich in diesem land dass sie
irgendetwas zu sagen wer sagt denn dass
die dort hinten sieht man jene des
bundes zu reden was sie gerne wollen
meint er und das ist der unterschied
zwischen olpe und moskau meine damen und
herren aus bedürfen sie schreien dürfen
sie trakehnen dürfen sie machen was sie
wollen nur nicht der cdu-chef dumm von
der seite anquatschen herr merz reden
sie mit mir war moderne politik oder
zumindest die cdu vorschlag zur güte sie
heben die antwort und herstellt im
anschluss die passende frage
können sie uns denn interview wenn sie
uns schon so abgedeckt ja die ganze zeit
herr merz wenn wir in die cdu eintreten
reden sie dann mit uns wir können da
noch einen job besorgen der
verwaltungsrat das ist super bezahlt
keine arbeit und die quoten sind besser
als die der cdu ich möchte mich auch
noch ausdrücklich entschuldigt war ihnen
für fabian künstlers für lutz van der
horst
ja also ich glaub er mag uns schon
alpen am niederrhein ein clan hält den
ort in atem sie nennen sich die junge
union die radikalen reformer treffen
sich in denkmalgeschützten häusern wir
sind beim wahlkampf in nrw na dann prost
es ist kurz vor elf zur deutschen flotte
hier beginnt also der wahlkampf jeden
tag für euch die ende der öfter gerne
mal aber es wird auch jetzt schon bier
getrunken das ist löblich wir müssen ja
die leute nachher ansprechen können
irgendwie trinkt ihr euch mut haben nein
[Gelächter]
die antwort kann ein bisschen
wie läuft der wahlkampf bisher zu für
euch was sind eure ersten eindrücke also
ganz persönlich muss jetzt sagen ist
viel besser als bei der bundestagswahl
und dann muss man sagen bei der
bundestagswahl war das anders und da
haben auch unsere leute also braucht man
sehr nahe stehen dann wenn ihr zum 15
mal von irgendjemand im vorbeilaufen
vorstellen dort gelebt ich habe immer
cdu will ich kann nicht mehr dann
demotivierte doch einfach mal so seid
ihr auch zu henrik wüst gegangen hab
gesagt du kannst alles machen aber
merkt der einst junge wenn du lachst ja
die bretter und keine masken verkauft
das ist natürlich schade wie gesagt
finde die partei versuchen leute die
ehrenamtlich aktiv sind das dann ganz
parteien geiselhaft genommen wird für 2
38 jährige leute dann haben die eigenen
leute noch ein bisschen mitgespielt und
getwittert aus bundesvorstandssitzung
hätte da war ja auch noch da
ist das immer so dass wenn man markus
söder erwähnt dass man sofort
könnten pilze haben
eins aber eins reicht ja
groß werden dass du und du bist auch
schon bei der
nur warum das segment als junger mann
macht gewisse äußerungen zur spd
bürgermeistern und dann kriegt man
anschreiben von der eu fast du den
bürgermeistern überhaupt also ich habe
ihm klar ins gesicht gesagt ich will
nichts von der spd wenn ich mal 14 bin
was ja dann jetzt so ist eigentlich in
die junge union ja und das kam dann die
rheinische post dann habe ich ein
anschreiben von der jungen union
bekommen warum hältst du nichts mit der
spd zu tun haben wie kam es dazu ich bin
auch in der landwirtschaft aktiv und
wenn man mit den landwirten spricht die
spd hat in ihrer amtszeit unter schmidt
und so landwirte ziemlich aggressiv
gemacht auf gut deutsch gesagt genau
wenn ich in meinen durch mein dorf
fahren und in der spd wäre dann würde
ich wahrscheinlich ein paar steine
hinterhergeworfen
ähnliches glaube ich kenn dich doch bist
du philipp am tor
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
so genug mut angetrunken
auf in den haustür wahlkampf
[Applaus]
und so läuft dieser wahlkampf für euch
also man klingelt an
vieles kann man jetzt auch den postboten
überlassen wir arbeiten hier arbeiten
und hier arbeiten eben viele leute und
die sind dann etwas zu verarbeiten
vielleicht noch nicht wieder geben ja ja
ja aber dann müssen sie auch die cdu
wählen
wie viel spargelschäler müsst ihr ihn
geben damit sie die cdu wählen müsste
selber sprache schälen und
der friede ist sie auch für den
wahlkreis ist dazu bestimmt aber naja
ich hab hier auf gebilden aber noch
nicht er wird alle fünf jahre ihre
stimme haben und deswegen
haben wir hier noch richtig
spargelschäler haben wir noch das jetzt
raus man muss die leute überzeugen
haben sie im kamin damit kann man super
heizen
an bekannte und verwandte
wir sind noch ein bisschen übermütig
hier beim häfen sind geschlossen werden
so dass schnell die
gez muss dann
ja und schon wieder eine stimme weniger
dankeschön
wie schafft die cdu ist denn bei so
zukunftsthemen wie klimawandel zum
beispiel wieder sattelfest zu werden sag
ich mal weil bei der letzten wahl haben
wir eine statistik gelesen von 46
prozent der wähler das thema am
wichtigsten nur elf prozent trauten der
cdu ja kompetenzen zu sehr verheerend
für so eine große partei oder total also
die grünen haben eine kompetenz
vermutung so ist der fachbegriff bei
klimawandel und ich finde da haben sich
die grünen auch verdient weil die ja
schon 20 jahre damit um die ecke
gekommen so und dass die cdu sich ein
kopf macht was machen wir beim
klimawandel das muss eine partei bringen
schon richtig so wer aber ganz gut wenn
sie dann mit was anderem um die ecke
gehen als die grünen die grünen haben ja
schon und wenn es zwei konzepte gibt
können wir auswählen
der rhein-hunsrück-kreis kommt man mit
der bahn schwer hin mit dem pferd geht's
nur leider können wir beide nicht reiten
aber wir sind trotzdem noch schneller
als mit der bahn stimmt hier schlägt
übrigens das grüne herz der cdu und es
gibt ein seltenes wetterphänomen
[Musik]
wir treffen thomas heilmann er ist
vorsitzender der klima union es gibt
eine klima union nach meiner kenntnis
ist das ja warum stehen hier eigentlich
so viele solarzellen gibt's dafür nicht
brandenburg
wir wollen ja überall erneuerbaren strom
und das herausragende den hunsrück wir
müssen halt 30 jahren ein cdu geführter
landkreis der erste und nämlich einzig
klimaneutrale landkreis und wer hat eben
sehr intelligent auf dieser alten
mülldeponie die nutzen will und verdient
einmal richtig geld damit der ganze
kreis ist ja jetzt klimaneutral ja aber
die eigentliche sensation ist dank einem
cdu politiker sollte bin ich ich sonst
hätte er das gemacht hat ja gar nicht
glauben jetzt einheimsen wir wollen in
eurer energien das wird manchmal nicht
zugetraut das stimmen aber ganz so ist
es nicht warum wird das jetzt nicht
zugetraut die cdu halte und tanker das
dauert halt bis so ein kranker sich
bewegt sie hat sich bewegt den letzten
jahren und aber ich finde im vergleich
eigentlich ganz gut die cdu ist quasi
die elfer geben die im suez kanal ist
steckt inzwischen ist er wieder los also
zwischen fahren wir wieder ja es geht
voran warum also eine cdu die titanic
das will ich nicht hoffen
also ich sehe auch kein eis lang auf uns
zukommen und dann gibt es ja dank cdu
ich habe vorgeschlagen dass wir uns hier
hingehen weil weil sie ja nicht glauben
dass die cdu auch was mit klimaschutz zu
tun hat und die machen das hier seit 30
jahren ja das ist wirklich unfassbar ja
affleck die cdu steht er sich in erster
linie für klimapolitik sie haben das
thema schon ende der 90er angeschoben
wurden sie dafür belächelt wir wurden
belächelt wir wurden gehänselt worden
kritisiert und seit 2009 10 würde ich
sagen hat sich der wind etwas gedreht
dann kamen europawahl freitag your
future naja und die letzten monate
brauche ich glaube ich nicht mehr zu
beschreiben und jetzt stellen wir etwas
anders da jetzt wird nicht mehr
gelächelt früher ging es nicht weil dann
die leute sich mehr über die eisbären am
nordpol unterhalten und die frage an die
zukunft oder können die malediven
überleben heute ist es mein nachbar
weiter gefährdet ist mein garten der aus
mein sylt mainz zb meine tiere die nicht
im feld und wald sehe das heißt wir sind
plötzlich persönlich getroffen deswegen
ist es nicht nur eine frage einer person
sondern ist auf breite basis jetzt
gestoßen also wenn wir es schaffen dass
wir einfach unnütze flächen mit
solarpanel zukleistern wir konnten den
zdf fernsehgarten anbieten das hat sich
der jogi wie
leute ich bin da häufiger und fernseher
dann hat das zdf ist super scheiß das
kann man nicht machen ernsthaft
fernsehgartens sind irgendwie im
flaggschiff so viel ich super schnell
ans aufhören dann sehen wir was essen
oder
[Musik]
warum die cdu die bundestagswahl
verloren hat vielleicht haben uns einige
mitglieder einfach nicht rechtzeitig ins
wahllokal geschafft
das durchschnittliche cdu-mitglied ist
nämlich 60 jahre alt
60,8 jahre und damit nicht von
durchschnittlichen zdf zuschauer zu
unterscheiden gleichzeitig fiel der
nachwuchs nur elf prozent der unter
30-jährigen wilten letztes jahr die und
jung noch weniger waren es nur bei den
unter 30-jährigen youtube und blauen
haaren das ist für die cdu deswegen
problematisch weil im vergleich zur wahl
2017 über eine million cdu-wähler
schlicht verstorben eine million nur um
das war deutlich zu machen den euro wäre
das gehobene mittelschicht aber wir
wollen sie nicht zu traurig in ihr
steckt natürlich gibt es auch in der cdu
so genug
schädigung und dann kommt es doch noch
zum großen exklusiv-interview
arbeitsfrühstück im bundestag zwischen
neuer verantwortung und bärchen wurst
wir dürfen ihm endlich treffen den mann
der die cdu aus dem tal der tränen führt
in eine neue zeit ja so kann man das
formulieren so genug schabernack kann
das buch gar nicht weiterlesen
vielleicht wenn du dich gut fühlst würde
ich vielleicht noch mal ein exemplar
irgendwie raus springen auch das muss
gar nicht
wir freuen uns jetzt so sein zum
arbeitsfrühstück ja sehr gut da bin ich
ja mal gespannt weil sie mit einer
einiges
fleisch wurst und unten veganen schinken
spicker was ist das veganer schinken
spieker ich weiß nicht also hat mich da
noch nicht so richtig ran getraut ich
habe die sorge es kommt schlecht an im
wahlkreis aber da muss man der eu laut
stunden auch so ein bisschen jahr aber
können auch jedem seinen veganen
schinken später aber gut soll jeder
essen die er will ich bin ja nicht hier
wie von den grünen dass ich allen leuten
vorschreiben was sie essen soll und was
nicht deswegen weil man das gerne mag
sie sind wirklich nicht wie von den
grünen das kann das
was sind die großen themen auf die die
cdu jetzt setzen sollte oder anders
gefragt von welchen themen würden sie
sich aktienoptionen holen also der war
natürlich auch gesehen führt das war
jetzt wirklich absehbar auch wirklich
wieder muss mal sagen was ihr oder war
das musste ich angst vor den reaktionen
angeboten dass er sich auf dem heute
steckt ja ja nein scherz beiseite das
ganze team hat mich sehr geärgert auch
damals ich mich vor allem über mich
selbst ist auch okay aber der blick
enthält ja eine ernsthafte frage was
sind jetzt die wichtigen themen deswegen
geht es ja gerade darum wir machen ein
neues grundsatzprogramm dass man auch
inhaltlich mal guckt was sind eigentlich
auch die schwerpunkte das war ja schon
so eines der probleme dass viele leute
nicht mehr wissen wofür steht die cdu
baut ja und vor allem dann gab es
natürlich auch so viel als sozi aktionen
zu sagen na ja die sowohl die cdu dass
wir immer nur zwei atomkraft und
verwerflich und irgendwie alles so wie
es vor 20 jahren bleibt also im cdu
programm stand drin familie ist vater
mutter kind das gegenteil gemacht da
stand drin wehrpflicht muss unterbleiben
haben das gegenteil gemacht da stand
drin atomkraft ganz wichtig die haben
das gegenteil gemacht also bisher hat
die cdu ihr eingeprägt haben einfach als
keiner liest ja oder das jetzt haben sie
die idee wir machen ein programm das wir
ernst nehmen und
das finde ich auch noch was ich die
revolution
junge leute wieder für die cdu zu
begeistern ist ja aktuell schon schwer
oder na ja es ist tatsächlich schon so
dass wir uns sehr geärgert haben über
das ergebnis bei der bundestagswahl
und das muss auch wieder besser werden
wichtig ist halt finde ich in dieser
ganzen diskussion dass man jetzt die
jugend in deutschland nicht irgendwie so
auf ein rollenmodell
reduziert also weder rieso noch ich noch
sonst wer repräsentiert jugend in
deutschland allein sondern die vielfalt
macht und die cdu ist halt nicht so eine
klientelpartei die dann sagt wir sind
nur für die mortadella essen den lasten
fahrradfahrer ja ich finde richtig gut
dass wir eben von friedrich merz bis
daniel günther und auch in der jungen
generation eine große breite an themen
haben aber da eine günther wurde
innerhalb der cdu schon genosse günther
immer genannt oder naja ich über mich
gibt es auch unschöne lücken in der welt
auch wenn keine an die keine ahnung
haben aber ich hab's aktien am tor ab
im kern ist es schon so dass natürlich
in einer partei gibt es auch mal sprüche
über den einen oder den anderen daniel
günther hat der breite akzeptanz für das
gute wahlergebnis und das finde ich auch
gut
hoch im norden hinter den deichen auf
zur wahlparty in schleswig holstein wir
sind natürlich vor ort in unserer
funktion als investigative neutrale
journalisten oder wir starten für daniel
günther schon mal die kanzler kampagne
oder so
[Applaus]
süßen
warum
nur
okay da sind die pferde etwas mit mir
durchgegangen aber die stimmung hier ist
auch echt geil
[Applaus]
ziemlich geiles erlebnis oder oder oder
absolut korrekt damit müssen sie jetzt
in berlin angreifen er jetzt ist kann
ich befinden berlin das war immer mein
ziel dass wir den fahrzeugen die mit i
park kommt ihr in schleswig holstein und
morgen bin ich auch bei der premiere
sicherheitsgesetze friedrich merz und ja
auch das brauche ich am morgen dann
schon als kleiner junge also von daher
im ergebnis kann man schon ein bisschen
rum zahlen dann auch in berlin das will
ich auch machen machen friedrich merz
kann vielleicht auch schon da nicht
unter diese fröhlichkeit aber die kommt
noch die kommt mit dem erfolg
haben sie mal in echt
lang war das sind keine und wahlrecht
der eltern
ernst friedrich wir haben versprochen
dass wir jetzt wegen stein liefern und
rückenwind für nrw geben wir haben das
gehalten ist okay oder hier bitteschön
muss man sagen wunde schlecht sitzendes
wieso habe ich wirklich nur wenn ich am
besten gleich laufen kannst aber das ist
doch schon mal wissen nicht woher
kommt es morgen bekommt er neunter
werden hier fragen sich das
ein bisschen
hier ich schätze mal aus schleswig
holstein kommt nein das kommt nicht so
schön
heißt wahrscheinlich morgen oder
was heißt denn grünen punktes leben
geschlossen
ist und was heißt das das heißt die
neue junge diesen dissens mit der woche
der song ist immer gut ihr versagen
nehme ich mir andere leute die mich
unterstützen hier müsse noch ein
bisschen wir hatten als slogan daniel
günther er ist das gegenteil von
friedrich merz
ist demokratie basiert das muss ich mir
gewünscht beim brainstorming
sie kommen auch oder
[Musik]
parteien funktionieren wie räuberbanden
der wirt räuberhauptmann der die größte
beute verspricht das heißt die cdu wird
sich den kopf machen wer holt für uns
die meisten prozente weil die meisten
prozent sind die meisten mandate sind
die meisten jobs aber danach werden
diese zeit sahnen sie jetzt ab bei einem
großen gewinnspiel beantworten sie nur
folgende frage was passt am wenigsten
zusammen der hsv und die erste liga
armin laschet und das kanzleramt oder
die cdu und frauen ok wat so einfach
hier die fakten 0 26 6 prozent der cdu
mitglieder sind frauen in der
bundestagsfraktion sind es sogar nur
23,5 prozent deswegen willi cdu im
september vielleicht sogar eine
frauenquote beschließen und wohl
kritikern der partei sagen dass ich dann
halt nicht wenn die qualität durchsetzt
wer war's egal nächste christ wie viele
der 15 cdu-landesverbände wäre von einer
frau geführt kleiner tipp die antwort
findet sich in frieden schmerz neuer
brille 0 und nochmal 0
aber werden sind auch die
cdu-landtagsfraktion nur von männern
geführt nein das wagemutige hessen
leistet widerstand dort gibt es eine
fraktionschefin und die heißt klaus kein
witz dieses klaus wahrscheinlich war es
also keine absicht sondern ein großes
missverständnis jedes du ich hab doch
bitte ausgewählt wie du heißt klaus
gibt's doch nicht ich brauche jetzt erst
mal ein ebbelwoi und jetzt live aus dem
bundestag in berlin das große cdu
welcher cdu politiker ist älter
friedrich merz
alt aber nicht so
friedrich merz ist für eine frauenquote
wenn uns zitat nichts besseres einfällt
frage hätte sagt ja
ist eigentlich schon es soll ein schöner
als das ist wirklich eine schöne aussage
ja das ist eine gute aussagen also wenn
sich seine frau wäre würde ich sagen
komm zu mir nach hause
warum ist die cdu keine coole partei für
junge leute hey wieso wir haben doch
philipp am tor b stimmt
oder b ja stimmt wir haben philipp am
tor ich finde nicht frisch und fangen
kann ist also sind die jungs die wir
schon einen film im sport geht nicht
gern in seiner eigenen mannschaft sind
aber einen disler oder heute auch dann
kommt da raus aus dem parlament ist sie
fühlen sie sich nicht zu sicher sobald
die linke mal wieder über 3 prozent das
machen wir auch das große linken es
jetzt sind sie uns zu unwichtig
was ist peinlicher eine bundestagswahl
gegen die spd zu verlieren oder b ein
signal des aufbruchs senden indem man
einen 66 jährigen mann der neunziger zum
parteichef macht jetzt antwortet inhalt
ihr habt ja so abgeräumt gerade mit den
stimmungen
ist aber so dass noch nicht abgearbeitet
ich würde sagen richtig
welcher cdu-landesverband wird von einer
frau geführt
rheinland-pfalz thüringen oder c
natürlich keiner so einen wichtigen job
kann man ja keiner frau überlassen
[Gelächter]
das glaube ich zurückgetreten thüringen
christine lieberknecht wir haben jetzt
eine stellvertretende generalsekretär
nicht verlegen jahren sehr guter
beispielsweise auch um frisches neues
gesicht und
gemeinsam handeln und ich gehe jetzt mal
ein bisschen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir müssen über die cdu reden
wir sind in etwa drei stunden
unterwegs bis
gleichwohl noch einbringen mit oder 2
catharina dos santos ist die jüngste cdu
abgeordnete im bundestag sie ist cool
sie ist modern und sie ist trotzdem in
der cdu wir haben fragen sind sie für
die cdu als junge moderne frau so was
wie eine entwicklungshelferin es ist
eigentlich schöne bezeichnung
glaube ich profitiere auch der von der
cdu und die cdu wäre ich nicht hier aber
ja es ist ein geben und nehmen als
eigentlich ein schönes bild wurde was
müsste die cdu denn ändern um
attraktiver für junge leute und auch
frauen zu werden also im wesentlichen
ein punkt gibt denen sich alle parteien
ging es mir überlegen müssen nämlich
wollen sich junge menschen und auch
frauen also eigentlich alle
bevölkerungsgruppen noch so an eine
partei binden oder ist es nicht auch
sinnvoll über projekt wirklich schafften
nachzudenken auf der anderen seite
müssen wir viel viel mehr dafür tun dass
zum beispiel junge familien sich
politisch engagieren können auch ein
ehrenabend also stichwort sitzungs
zeiten bei kommunalen ehrenämtern in
zeiten wo man danach auch nicht mehr
abstimmen kann wirksam beispielsweise
damit könnten wir schon ganz viel tun
aber projekt mitgliedschaft also wie das
ich mir mal so viel natur auf bali hat
stechen lassen sage ach damals sah war
ich auch mal für fünf monate in der cdu
aber ich sehe nicht mehr machen so war
weiß ich nicht
[Musik]
finden sie es nicht schade dass sie die
große zeit der cdu verpasst haben ich
glaube in die cdu hat auch noch eine
große zeit vor sich also ich fühle mich
da gehört ganz gut wo ich bin der aber
so diese 16 merkel jahren da war schon
andere romane also als wir da immer im
bundestag waren daher waren die
kardinäle und kraft strebt war der satz
wieder kaum laufen ja ja was kann
friedrich merz von jemandem wie ihnen
lernen mal abgesehen von allem
ich glaube friedrich merz kann von mir
lernen einen neuen blick auf den
bundestag so ich war habe die die zeit
60 jahre merkel nur vom fernseher aus
miterlebt und ja auch gut wetter zu
machen
aber ich glaube ja keinen neuen blick
lernen dann kann es vielleicht auch eine
lebensrealität von jemandem lernen der
jungen als frau auf dem land zum
beispiel aufgewachsen ist und
da kann ja nur vom profitieren glaube
ich was ist denn so die lustigste
geschichte die da erzählt bekommen haben
ja wir wollen ablachen ja also ich
glaube die lustigste geschichte ist
zeigt sich im moment eine die ich sogar
selber miterlebt habe bei der
bundesversammlung als werbe bars michael
donath aufgerufen aktion michael michael
bont und er hat darüber dann in der
landesgruppe eine schachtel tun als mit
gebracht bekommen heißt seitdem auch
michael donath also die geschichte fand
ich schon ganz gut aber alles andere
fällt vielleicht unter die abgeordneten
schweigepflicht da geht noch was soll
ich sagen würde ich auch sie sind der
neue jung ich hoffe da kommen ein paar
lustige anekdoten deswegen bin ich ja
hier ja dann würde ich noch ein bisschen
zeit hab mir lustige geschichten
zusammen
o
während fabian noch eine runde cocktails
holt wartet auf mich eine überraschung
es gibt noch eine junge frau in der cdu
sie sind das jüngste mitglied im cdu
präsidium das heißt sie sind krasser als
philipp amt wurde wir sind ein bisschen
unterschiedliche typen würde ich schon
sagen ja was heißt das konkret die sagen
unterschreiben sie sich ich habe meinen
führerschein auch
woran liegt das dass das ist dann doch
so wenig frauen sind also auch was die
mitglieder angeht ein viertel sind nur
frauen woran liegt das das müssen wir
auf jeden fall mehr werden das stimmt ja
werten schon viele gute vorbilder angela
merkel als prominentestes beispiel aber
an einigen stellen müssen wir da schon
noch nachbessern er ist tatsächlich sehr
gering also noch geringer ist er nun der
afg
ja ich glaube dass wir manchmal nicht so
gut kommuniziert bekommen dass er
eigentlich auch ziemlich gute angebote
für die frauen in der cdu wie stehen sie
denn zu einer frauenquote
sollte man zumindest nicht ausschließen
der parteitag wird entscheiden im herbst
also sollte man nicht ausschließen heißt
es jetzt finden sie gut oder fühlen sich
nicht gut
ein großer fan bin ich nicht aber ich
habe meine meinung dazu den letzten
jahren auch ein bisschen relativiert und
glauben sich friedrich merz ist dann der
richtige mann um jetzt durchzustarten
jetzt auf jeden fall und alessandro
germeroth deswegen haben sie auch für
herrn röttgen
sie können jetzt nochmal entschuldigung
sagen in die kamera sie müssen doch mal
ihre karriere denken
was hält denn friedrich merz von so
einer frauenquote
ich hege den verdacht dass es ihm egal
ist es gibt ja in der cdu leute die
sagen wir brauchen das unbedingt und es
gibt leute die sagen das dürfen wir auf
keinen fall machen weil das irgendwie
linkes teufelszeug und ich glaube märz
dass es im kern egal und ich hege den
verdacht dass er eine lösung sucht die
ihm am wenigsten ärger macht
ich habe inzwischen alle
bundestagsdebatten der 80er geguckt und
mir nun bestens vorbereitet auf die
grand dame der cdu rita süßmuth
ich wollte zum auflockern mit was
lustigem anfangen jetzt tun sie ist die
cdu eine moderne partei
sie versuchte zu werden
die frauenfrage schwieger
scheint wir ja problem zu sein damit sie
muss gelöst werden was glauben sie denn
was zuerst passiert dass die menschheit
den klimawandel besiegt oder dass die
cdu zu gleichen teilen frauen und männer
hat schöne frage gute frage aber ich
musste ihnen sagen diese beiden themen
kann man heute nicht mehr von der trend
also der klimawandel ist mit der cdu
verbunden und mit frauen in der cdu dann
sind wir ja verloren ja ich musste ihnen
sagen das muss gleichzeitig geschieht
aber das eigene zutun und dann das
andere zu lassen ihr frauen könnte ja
noch mal warten das ist doch ein
gemeinsamer auftrag den anteil im
parlament gehen wir jetzt haben mit 24 4
x 6 und die prozesse ist für dir
gefallen da kann ich nur sagen es ist
das gefühl verändert jetzt hat ja die
mittelstands- union gefordert man soll
die basis entscheiden lassen klar wenn
man aber weiß dass die basis ja auch zu
über 70 prozent männer die
basisbefragung ich an sich verstecken
vor einer weltlichen
verbalen
auseinandersetzung wenn jetzt manche
männer aus ihrer partei sagen aber wieso
wir haben doch jetzt immerhin eine vize
generalsekretärin
da fühlt man sich doch auch leicht
verarscht auf deutsch sagen das ist so
nach dem motto eine schwalbe macht jeden
sommer das sind ja in den
bergen jetzt finde hier gehörte auch mit
lauter kleinen
ich will keine kurven und man kann mich
auch fragen warum sind sie in die cdu
will aber ich habe mir gedacht wo ist
die meisten arbeit dann bedanke ich mich
und denken sie immer daran sie haben ja
jetzt immerhin vize generalsekretärin
das ist doch schon mal was
da denke ich aber
ich begnüge wichtig damit dann wünsche
ich ihnen viel glück sie werden es
brauchen ja
ja das wird aber zum schluss dieses
spezials bleiben sie immer ein paar
fragen offen wenn man jetzt in die cdu
eintritt könnte man der nächste
bundeskanzler werden sie glaube ich
nicht aber
und wer hat eigentlich diese bescheuerte
idee mit den pferden
[Musik]
und welcher frage sollte man demnächst
mal nachgehen
die antworten gibt es spätestens dann
wenn fabian und wird zurück in köln sind
und das kann dauern
[Musik]
und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe fans der feinsten unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere videos
sehen wollt
das war super tag
wir haben ich sehe auch echt clique aus
heute